this is a happy occasion am i right lily
aren't you excited to get a new baby
brother no i hate the baby
i just hope that the problem is she
hasn't spent much time with any baby so
we thought it would be a great idea to
show her how much fun it'll be to have
one around oh is this lily oh yes it is
hey honey say hi to the baby
my daddy oh
okay well that's one problem solved
not too many at once you're doing great
lil she is isn't she forget the bride
all the eyes are going to be on her
i want to watch that claire okay well
first honey we need to talk about
something it's about that word you said
this morning
what word you know the one that starts
with f
flower no
fruit no if she doesn't remember it we
shouldn't remind her well she said it
three times oh you mean
cam leave the room
nope
i can do this
lily
that is a bad word and you are not
allowed to say it ever but it makes you
laugh okay well daddy shouldn't be
laughing and you should never say that
word
do you understand maybe
okay this is not a game oh no what a
glorious wait stop stop crying but just
because you have ice water in your veins
does it mean no no lily
n no lily he's fine oh daddy's not sad
daddy daddy
[Laughter]
see i told you it was funny
[Music]
so good i want a cheeseburger this is a
special soup called pho you told me not
to say that word it is delicious this is
the food of your people can i get you
anything else actually um we're just
trying to teach our daughter about your
country and as i'm saying that i'm
hoping you're from vietnam i was born
there
so was lily oh it's a beautiful country
uh my family still lives there i hate
vietnam lily honey we don't hate i hate
vietnam
okay oh we need just a second
lily that was rude i want to go home no
it's important that you celebrate the
culture of your ancestors you are
vietnamese no i'm not i'm gay i'm gay
look at you my big first grader all
right i want you to make so many friends
and have so much fun i gotta go
can't wait to learn be careful what
[Music]
nothing you guys cool if i check off no
sweetie what's been going on with you
you've wanted to leave since we got here
hey y'all coming
might as well come on lily let's go
dance no no dancing is too embarrassing
no you're a good dancer sweetie not me
you two what you don't like our dancing
why
why
[Music]
you're not good that's why i hate
weddings wait lily did you rush repeat
at some weddings and not tell us yes
punish me ground me i just can't watch
it again oh you're gonna be punished
mitchell wait i know how she feels did
we really embarrass you that bad well
yeah i mean i still love you but
why are your shoulders moving well we
always knew there would be something you
didn't like about us we're just glad
that it's something we're so good at
[Music]
if anybody asks i'm with you
okay are we gonna go outside yes we are
careful uh how many times have i told
you not to leave this here someone's
gonna trip on it there's a lot going on
with me right now my body's changing
okay you always use that hey today
you're gonna learn about responsibility
today you are gonna take care of a baby
do you want a toy
a little tough love
long overdue if you ask me
but it's gonna be good for you sweetie
he's crying well that's what babies do
you just gotta pick it up and you gotta
soothe it
all right then
okay okay
it worked good just keep it up for the
rest of the afternoon
wait i don't know what i'm supposed to
do well welcome to being a parent
no no no no no take those things off
please we need to talk about whatever's
going on with you right now i'm fine no
you're not fine you're sullen and aloof
and and you embarrassed us in front of
kimmy love insta i can't say it again i
can't okay we gave you every tween
girl's dream day and and you could
barely crack a smile it's not my dream
day it's yours i'm not the same kind of
tween girl you guys are but we love all
the same things i've changed i don't
like beyonce ooh take that back or
brittany or gaga oh i only fake it cause
you guys like that stuff
i'm different well honey is it
is that why you've been feeling so down
because you you feel different than us i
don't know i guess i feel different than
a lot of people well
sweetie that is one thing your dad and i
can relate to i guess
that's the great thing about having two
gay dads we we know what it feels like
to be an outsider okay but here's what
happens you start finding people who
don't quite fit in and you start not
fitting in together we never once should
feel like you have to be someone else
for us never
what is this music you're always
listening to come on let us in yeah okay
i like this let's put it on huh here we
go
[Applause]
yeah yeah i like it
she's gonna kill us something all right
remember we used to spend all of our
birthdays here and spuddy holly would
always sing to us
spuds potatoes amaze happy birthday i
wanna stress that i'm adopted why are
you sure we put the car seats in right
what do you mean we uh uh i don't know
it felt shaky oh god this is bad this is
really bad we don't have diapers we
don't have formulas even know where we
live if somebody asked for an address
what am i supposed to say some new house
someplace guys oh my gosh oh oh my god
oh my god we're awful we haven't even
checked in with you you you must be
freaking out too no i'm not and neither
are you this is just your process you
get hysterical you worry about every
detail then you turn on each other no we
don't yes we do how dare you and after
all that craziness when it really
matters the most you
what wha what do we do
our son
he's beautiful
we got this
[Music]
you